Sam what do you get excited about well
strangely the what excites me is just
really just a butts the the parts that
scare me the most I think what is nice
about this conversation in particular
about the alignment problem is that it's
forcing us to realize that there are
better and worse answers to questions of
human value and as someone said perhaps
that this last meeting in Puerto Rico
that we have we really we really have to
do philosophy on a deadline and we have
to we have to admit to ourselves that
there are better and worse answers and
we have to converge on the better ones
and what would excite me about actually
the birth of super intelligent AI one of
the things apart from solving obvious
problems like curing disease and energy
issues and all the rest but is perhaps
differs a little bit with what Stuart
said I am not so worried about idiocracy
or all of us just losing our way as apes
and living unproductive lives in
dialogue with these these Oracle's I
think actually I would want a truly
value aligned super intelligence to
incrementally show us not not not merely
conservative what we want but show us
what we should want to get to keep
improving our values so that we can we
can navigate in the space of all
possible experiences and converge on on
better and better ones